we are learning new information tonight
about communication between two key
players in the Justice Department
investigation of the 2016 Trump campaign
even after the election chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Herridge reports nine days after the
presidential election FBI agent Peters
Strunk an FBI lawyer Lisa Paige
exchanged texts that Fox News has
learned are under new scrutiny by
congressional investigators reviewing
the genesis of the FBI Russia probe the
string of texts refer to an email and
prior briefing with pence presumably
vice president-elect Mike Pence struck
in Paige then appeared to discuss
strategy and staffing for an upcoming
session Paige rights would it be unusual
to have show up again maybe another
agent from the team struck response or
he's the counterintelligence guy same
might make sense he can assess if there
are any new questions or different
demeanor
if redacted husband is there he can see
if there are people we can develop for
potential relationships a former FBI
intelligence specialist said the texts
appear to conflict with strict rules
made up by then FBI director robert
muller known as the domestic
investigations operations guide quote
these tacks indicate both FBI employees
were executing investigative strategies
on a sensitive investigative matter
without any regard for the Moller
endorsed guide with the Moller report
complete and Republican Senator Lindsey
Graham leading the Judiciary Committee
struck may find himself back on the hill
I am certain Congress will absolutely
have the opportunity to look at any
investigation once it's closed asked all
these questions and I would love to
answer each and every one of your
questions the Attorney General recently
testified he is conducting a review of
the FBI probes origins and whether
surveillance of the Trump campaign was
based on sound intelligence in a
statement Republican congressman Devin
Nunez said of the tax quote this is yet
more evidence that the FBI's trump
Ruscha investigation was filled with
irregularities there was no immediate
response from lawyers for struck in Page
and late today in a letter to the
Attorney General Republican senators
Chuck Grassley and Ron Johnson said
these texts and other incidents should
investigated adding quote any improper
FBI surveillance activities must be
brought to light and properly addressed
Chris Catherine thank you